e
bataille ce fait, d'attaque sera
davantage une bataille de
militants, alors qu'au au
igigigan, ce sera une bataille
- À l'oratoire Saint-François-
de-Sales, esesesse est célébrée
en latin tous les dimanches.
Chaque semaine, des centaines
Dans cette communauté catholique
traditionaliste, la décision de
l'État du Missouri de légiférer
pour criminaliser l'avortement
fait l'unanimité.
Oratoire Saint-François-de-Sales
- Tuer un enfant sans défe
c'est le... on va dire,
le plus grand crime.
- Pierre Dumain est vicaire
Il s'est toujours défini
comme un pro-vie, et maintenan
il partage ses convictions
avec les jeunes de
sa communauté. Mais cela va
- Ce n'est pas parce que je suis
catholique que je ne tue pas.
Un athée ne tue pas, non,
un être humain, on ne tue pas
un être humain. Et donc,
donc, on ne tue pas l'embryon.
- Ici, les familles sont
nombreuses, l'avortement
n'est pas une option,
même en cas den,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,nt
pourquoi il y a des viols?PoPoP?
Pourquoi il y a ce manque
de respect pour la femme?
de l'oratoire, on trouve
la seule clinique ororortement
de tout le Missouri. Mais depuis
vendredi, quiconque y pratique
de grossesse s'expose à une
peine de 5 à 15 ans riririson.
C'est devenu un crime,
au même titre qu'un homicide
TANIA THOMAS,
résidente de St-Louis
- Choc... j'avais entendu que
c'était quelque chose qui...cuci
jamais pensé qu'ils prendraient
les droits aux femmes.
au Missouri depuis plus
de 25 ans. Mère de deux filles,
elle craint que cela ne s'arrête
- Le mariage entre
deux personnes du même sexe,
ou bien... hum, les autres
- La file e e Tania est
doctorante en médecine.
Elle sent que son avenir
dans une clinique venant en aide
à des fs s s victimes
de violences conjugales.
domino, dit-elle.
JADE THOMAS,  doctorante
en médecine
En violence conjugale,
la grossesse est utiliséeodododt
garder les femmes prisonnières
de ce modèle de génération
en génération."
cette décision aura un effet
positif dans les États qui
suivront l'exemple du Missouri.
les différences entre les États
après quelques années, dans
les États qui vont interdire
vont continuer l'avortement,
et on va voir la différence.
Les États qui vont s'effondrerd.
de tissu social parce qu'il
n'y a plus d'enfants...
qui menace le tissu social
du Missouri.
Ici Valérie Gamach